hey guys how's it going I'm making out
with Josh so what do we do then do you
know what we're gonna do uh yeah we're
gonna make a cake yes we are so I've
already prepped a few cakes but we've
got to make a couple more because my
plan is we're going to put your book
inside oh okay like a big cake yeah it's
yeah because when you were first filming
the idea I imagined it would be like
laying this way it would just be like
one cake yeah but yeah this is gonna be
like a pretty tall cake for it to be
standing vertical so we're also gonna do
another cake on josh's channel so you
doesn't have to go and check that out
but first let's talk about the book the
last time you came out with a book we
baked another cake so we thought we
should probably celebrate and try to
outdo that one and look at the color
scheme but just I mean yeah pop quiz
right in the comments left or right
which one is the book and which one is
the cake you'll probably get it wrong
it's I'm sure it's gonna be another
beautiful cake the last one it was like
it really couldn't tell which one was
the cake and what was the book which one
is which you don't know so why did you
book them out how's it going what's it
about
tell us everything yeah so it's my first
novel my last book was I'm not more so
like true stories about me and my dating
disasters and then this is like a
made-up story except fiction yeah and
it's about a blind teenager who gains
sight for the first time and when he
does he finds out that his friends have
been keeping a secret about the visual
world I haven't read it yet so don't
don't spoil it
there's no that's not a spoiler okay I
know but don't see anything else okay
I'm so excited I'm gonna be traveling
actually a couple of days so this is
gonna be my travel book okay very
excited so you get to check it out I'll
put a link in the description and
without further ado we're gonna bake
some freakin cakes
also are you ready yeah okay I love you
are we're talking the Internet where to
me on who is ready sometimes I ask
myself
all day long or them so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna make four cakes we're
gonna make them really fast okay I gotta
go to the cake cakes - that's just so
much cake if people know how much take
your house oh yeah this is my probably
third time today
yeah just like what I do this is
actually my third time that's yeah thing
is that you actually do bake cakes all
the time watch so many cakes
it's like I think probably the last time
I bake the cake was our video okay so
we're gonna need 2 cups of water so you
can go ahead and use to cut it open
funfetti a normal one so it's just like
like that's less fun fun how do you feel
about cracking eggs all right
[Music]
there's one gig just get that y'all this
is great
all right so these cakes are going into
the oven and we'll be back with a big
stack of cakes it's gonna be awesome
in just a few seconds good 12 of them it
doesn't we gotta figure out we're gonna
cut and it's gotta be even all the way
you never know when you're gonna need
some kitchen light Jose I think that's
good yeah they're gonna fit well now do
you have to try to level this to make it
whoa actually what is that this is a
cake leveler because they don't keep it
nice and rubble yeah definitely more
stable looks like like an assassin's
device okay so it really looks like a
weapon careful I don't want to
assassinate your oh yeah I feel like
this is a real West world huh yeah no
it's like yeah it's like smooth Dexter
that looks good great job I'm super
impressed this is like the new library
Wow
I'm in France oh this is cool
good luck fries don't even use morrow
[Music]
Wow Wow this is great
we're gonna be like two more
look inside here Wow look like a book
except the opposite it's pretty
impressive though do you know if it's a
book inside we're gonna push it cools it
up yeah okay so forth all right sighs
going in the book what going in cake oh
yeah really I mean it depends on on your
position yeah you're like look at the
universe is the cake going in the book
or is the book I'm in the cake
you guys let us know yeah really depends
on your perspective
yeah oh yeah it's so well this is great
Oh perfect right bit perfect okay I
think for this I'm gonna use this big
guy
[Music]
it's really good
you know can we put a bulb on probably
should have bought more I didn't realize
cake math I couldn't know they're gonna
show up it's the white icing yeah look
close look like dots again a smiley face
underneath salvages if we put finely in
the middle like oh yeah that's a really
good idea actually I think they'll be no
really tickets the next level hmm I
can't be worse
well it's nice
nice look good everything's incredible
[Music]
okay so also the fake checks the book so
the face is this way or the book is like
this so I'd like to cut into it so that
we can like oh yes see it inside good
that's a book that's the book
I'm touching the book okay
well we're gonna have like just amazing
just from the top know what's gonna
happen
[Music]
surprise books but the layers are these
look you would never know how like
uneven and wobbly it was just like the
layer and like the icing in between each
one yeah I'm impressed crazy
yeah Wow it's gonna fall in five four no
back up honey back up yeah it's yeah
that was really smart to run man I had a
feeling I had a feeling that was gonna
happen
yeah it was like you like new it's like
right it's gonna fall right here cake
matha falling oh my god
as if you perhaps have a lot of
experience with cakes falling I do know
this is where your practice came in
handy yeah you can do plenty thought
well
all right that's it we've got a cake
massacre but I think overall it was
pretty successful yeah I mean it was
amazing it was like so tall they held
the book in and we cut it out
cake surprise it's amazing first night
first sight percent book inside of a
cake I mean literally was my first sight
yes that's true
I make sure you check out josh's channel
I'll put a link in the description to a
video that we just also did together on
his and where can we find more
information about the book love and
first sight comm for information about
like where to find it and more about
what's about it and I put a link also in
the description go see you guys later
bye oh god I'm sweating I'm sweating
okay good not super fun funny it looks
very cool agree where do we put water in
it I did okay this looks really
different from the other did you put it
three
well it is slippery and villains were
lucky not